[Musique]
pourquoi parade parade je voulais jouer
sur le jouer sur le mot en fait parce
qu'il ya 200 sa part ali a ce côté où on
parlera dans la rue on défile on se
montre mai puis elle aussi la parade du
arts martiaux en fait où on se défont
rencontre contre un ennemi on compare
les coûts etc
[Musique]
e
le
beaucoup de gens là c'est la couleur et
la fête mode textures et des quelque
part tu vas voir les couleurs et c'est
dur d'expliquer que c'était pas
forcément ce qui m'intéressait parce que
ça qu'avec le noir et blanc une fois
qu'on a mis de la couleur de côté on a
accès à un autre
un autre niveau de langage et on peut
rentrer dans de l'émotion on peut
rentrer dans des détails c'est à dire
qu'on va pas chercher ce qui nous
impressionne plus que ce qui est raconté
en fait ce qui m'intéresse c'est rang ce
qui est raconté par chacune des images
[Musique]
cette photo elle s'appelle lost
generation c'est la première photo qui
m'a qui m'a vraiment marqué quand j'ai
commencé ce projet sert je savais même
pas encore ce sera un projet je me
balade dans les rues de fort de france
et je tombe sur cet homme qui est en
train de se déguiser en femme qui afin
de pousser une poussette avec je sais
pas combien de bébés en tout cas il ya
beaucoup de bébés et ils ont des
cigarettes dans la bouche et c'est vrai
que ça m'a l'impression de voir une
image en transparence de la société dans
laquelle on vit du pays
lost generation c'est un peu c'est une
génération perdue comme comme si une
transmission n'avait pas eu lieu voix
[Musique]